it was a food experience that I've had
I'm starting all over again I'm [ __ ]
out let's do this again [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] here we go
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to the best
food review slash mukbang channel on the
face of this [ __ ] planet and if
you've seen other ones they're trashed
mmm today you guys are in for a treat
because we are going to be eating one of
my favorite cuisines and only until
recent years that I even knew know that
this existed we're talking about Burmese
food from Myanmar or Myanmar formerly
known as Burma
ba-ba-ba-ba Burma this food is very
interesting when I first had Burmese
food I didn't know what to expect but
slowly but surely it became one of my
favorite cuisine so we're just gonna go
through some of my favorite dishes that
I've eaten from the burmese me i'm
rooney's people's y'all ready for this
first fish up let's go today's first
contender is tea leaf salad oh my
friends you guys are in for a treat now
I'm not sure if this is actually eaten
as a meal or if it's like a bar food
snack or if it's like some kind of
cultural thing any people from Myanmar
if you can enlighten me on tea leaf
salad please let me know but I'm just
gonna give you guys a few piece of info
Maceo Nez as they say in Spanish about
tea leaf salad now a leaf salad consists
of a lot of different things you're
gonna taste a lot of nuttiness because
yes there are like nuts
I believe fried in oil but the main
component that you'll see in this aside
from all the other stuff is this piece
of elephant poop on the side this is
fermented tea leaves now don't be scared
my friends because I know it looks like
a bird [ __ ] of this out of its ass and
then we're gonna use it as food you know
Asian people we do some weird [ __ ]
but Burma I believe or Myanmar is one of
the few areas where they actually eat
the leaves and not just steep it for tea
and for drinking purposes and when I
first saw this I wasn't sure what I was
going to expect when I eat ate this but
I gotta tell you like I always say with
food one of my favorite things on earth
so let's practice my friends we are
going to take these cute little limes
you know these little delicious little
lie
then you're gonna squeeze the
[ __ ] on there pop pop pop I love
limes limes over lemons for me it's my
[ __ ] yeah you know why limes are better
because when you get a shitty car you
don't call it a lime you call it a
[ __ ] lemon Oh when you get this in a
restaurant too by the way the
presentation will be a lot better you'll
see it you know pushed off to the side
or they'll organize all the nuts and the
tomatoes and everything else but I got
it to go just to show you guys so you're
just gonna mix all this stuff together
the flavors that you're getting gonna
get is gonna be fish sauce you're gonna
get these fried nuts I'm not sure it
might be peanuts or what do you call
those what do you call those things mung
beans or or whatever I don't know
this is this is one of those cuisines I
really don't have too much knowledge
about I just know it's bona [ __ ]
tomatoes in there cabbage as well fish
sauce sesame oil and you'll be surprised
how delicious it I doubt this is really
that healthy but I'm not really worried
about that not all salads have to be
healthy as hell
sometimes it just has to be [ __ ]
delicious I personally like this with a
nice Bossier also known as beer for you
Oh layman's but there we go nice and
mixed as I just get a little it's always
amazing
it's gonna have a little bit of a kick
to it because there are those there is
chilly in there but that fish sauce
which if you're Asian you always love
it's gonna add that as I always say
umami just that next six cents level of
taste crunchy cabbage oh man and the
fried nuts mmm it's gonna oh my god it
was like heat you get that bright lime
in there and the tea leaf is what really
sets it off for me I know when you're
thinking about like fermented food some
of you might be turned off by it but
when it comes to Asian food that we do
use a lot of fermented vegetables but
there's no specifically Koreans like
kimchi kimchi is a fermented cabbage but
have this and you won't be disappointed
and I'm talking about texture and flavor
here oh man we really dishes like this
you don't miss me and that's what I love
about Asian foods there's actually a lot
of like vegetarian vegan slash
pescetarian and well in this States
because I use fish sauce dishes that
don't require for you to have a huge
piece of protein to be satisfied with
your meal this is obviously something
that's not going to be a meal per se but
if you're starting off your meal of this
you're having the drink you're kicking
with a bunch of friends and you just
want to snack this right here
it's interesting cuz when I go either
places the last thing I usually want is
a salad I just think Asian people just
do salads better than white people I
don't know American people
I feel like salads is it something that
people create in Asia just to be like
what was the healthier version of
something it's just more like this this
can be the main dish there's like a
flavor bonanza like it doesn't stop
spicy salty and then you have that
cabbage that just soaks up all the
flavor and all the seasonings and that
my friend is tea leaf salad oh god I
spit on you guys next up my friends is a
very popular and apparently very typical
dish that you'll see and a lot of
Burmese cuisine I believe this is
pronounced Jo even though it's spelt kya
y-space
oh you know how I am people be they
always like to make [ __ ] confusing ha ha
this right here is BOM as [ __ ] if
you're a protein level you're gonna
definitely love this I got the pork
version of it inside this you will see
pieces of like Chinese bok choy this
right here is that pork that ground pork
that they have this is like a fish ball
I believe or some sort of that quail
eggs and tofu on the side and you could
have this either wet so it's kind of
done in a broth like uh I guess you
would say or you could had the soup on
the side I'm always told to get the soup
on the side because they said that it's
way more flavorful than getting it
without that and over here you of course
have to have your hot sauce because I
think people in Burma just like spicy
food as you can tell because I'm
sweating as a [ __ ] first off
before we even put that hot sauce on in
there ooh spices and also if you notice
on this there's going to be pieces of
fried garlic yes let's have a little bit
of everything here a little bit of
vegetable a little bit of that oh that
noodle pull action right there
mm-hmm
so [ __ ] good I love the fried garlic
and that soy flavor sauce that they put
on there me I'm definitely some hot
sauce on this BZ spiciest [ __ ] we're
gonna dodge those little [ __ ] devil
dick Chili Peppers mm-hmm that's what's
up you know with the soup - I've seen
people drink it separately Bob and I
also see people pour it on top me I
don't think I'm gonna pour some on here
just to moisten it up like that now
we're talking
heat sweet and a little bit of spice but
this is definitely a really BOM savory
dish and if you've never bought clay
like of course I love boilers man
it's the [ __ ] I needed more spice up on
this [ __ ] man I like to have my [ __ ]
come out my [ __ ] later mmm yes these
delicious noodles have absorbed that
brought that I just poured on there
oh yeah you definitely need this
vinegary hot sauce with this because
without it I mean it's very delicious
but you have fried garlic you already
have the noodles and the pork gets
really heavy heavy heavy heavy and then
when you add the spice to it it just
kind of it mixes it up a little bit you
need that heat and you need that vinegar
just to always balance out like
fattiness and crazy saltiness oh yeah
let's get into this piece of pork right
here mm-hmm
and that'd be support too isn't just
like ground-up pork it's they flavor it
I taste like ginger I taste garlic a
little more hot sauce on this
oh man I feel like this is a dish I
could eat almost every day a lot of
protein bunch of flavor and who doesn't
like noodles those are the reason why I
can't do like keto diets and all the
other stuff is because I love noodles
and rice carbs on my [ __ ] the cool thing
about this rice noodle that they're
using it literally absorb every bit of
sauce that they put in there and just
soaked it all up so every time you eat
it like I said before flavor bomb a
little more soup in this delicious
let's get that quail egg up in this I'm
waiting no and let's add some hot sauce
on that and
bama's [ __ ] next up my friends is a must
have must have must have oh [ __ ] must
have huh when you go to a Burmese place
make sure that you get the mohinga what
is Mohini got my friend is a cat fish
soup with noodles inside now the
prevalent flavor in this is going to be
all those choices of herbs and spices
that you'll see in a lot of the food
that you have I believe it's made with
the fish paste as well and they put
catfish obviously in there too and that
catfish water flavors or soup you'll see
hints of like tumeric I believe shallots
garlic onions it's just gonna be all of
those delicious flavors meld it together
that puts you in a very happy place now
mohinga it might even be a breakfast
food I'm not quite sure about that as
well I'm just saying a lot of
information that I don't know about and
then you guys are probably gonna correct
me in the comments you [ __ ] fat
police [ __ ] but please do I actually
do want to know fried garlic as well
cilantro on the side lime there spices
and of course eggs and always add the
lime in there like that taste the soup
after you mix it up
like that and as you can see their
spices on the side that I'm gonna mix in
the soup and this is my [ __ ] flavorful
flavorful as hell you do Kate taste the
catfish and mohinga too you'll see it
come in different colors as well this
one is more Brown I mean I think
typically I seen like this by help I've
also seen milking got more on the
reddish orange side catfish is something
to this like a hit or miss for people
some people don't like catfish because
it has like that muddy it kind of tastes
like the environment that they stay
around which is at the bottom of like
fresh water like ponds or [ __ ] lakes
but I actually like it especially with
mohinga so BOM savory yep yep
mm-hmm could you get a bite of the
noodles and then you get some of that
egg too on the side and that cilantro to
brighten it up oh yeah
the mohinga brach tube is thicker then a
lot of other like noodle soups that you
probably used to but I like it cuz it
clings to everything the garlic to the
shallots garlic and shallot to ultimate
combo by the way I feel like if you cook
garlic and onions or shallots together
it already smells like you know what the
[ __ ] you're doing sometimes back in the
day gonna have a girl come over I just
pretend like I'm cooking and just
throwing Carlie and that into a pan and
she's like oh my god you're such an
amazing cuz I'm not no I'm not [ __ ] got
you and sloppy if you eat this then
you'll be like whoa I don't know what
category to place us into it just
doesn't taste like any other foot well
maybe it kind of has like similarities
to me in my opinion anyways to a lot of
Indonesian food that I've had but even
then it's their way different from that
as well I said I wasn't gonna finish
this I'm probably fizzes at this point
you don't really need the fork in the
spoon in my personal opinion you just
it's all sauce and DLitt you can see all
that flavor juice right there
you drink it eat it at the same time
like so this is the last dish that we
will be eating this my friends I don't
actually know how to pronounce it but
I'm guessing it's ohno ohno noodle but
it's a chicken noodle soup main in a
coconut chicken broth typically I heard
it's made with wheat noodles I don't
even know what that should taste like
but we have eggs in here once again this
delicious fry stuff which I have no idea
and that reoccuring like all those mung
beans I called him I guess a bean
fritter type of thing which is that fry
stuff that you saw the tea leaf salad
you saw it in the the cabbage noodle
soup as well which is these cute little
delicious crunchy bits right there
cilantro spices and this creamy creamy
soup I like coconut soup base bras and
you'll see that with like you know Thai
coconut soup so I was like familiar
flavor why not give it a go
we're gonna bite into this right now see
how all that like soup and brought it
clings to the noodles welcome good yep
that's what I'm talking about
it's very coconut for it obviously but
when you look at a dish and it's bright
yellow bright red you're thinking spicy
it's gonna be super in-your-face it's
not it's extremely mild and kind of like
with Thai food like Thai food it tastes
as intense as it looks this on the other
hand it does not so if you're scared
when you look at this and you think that
it's just gonna be too much for your
palate trust me give this a go
[Music]
and you will be pleasantly surprised
grab yourself some egg get those little
pieces of chicken
I love that fried bean fritter it's so
it's good it's just it tastes like um
how'd it taste like the breading on the
outside of a fried piece of chicken you
know it's not a part of the main dish
but it's still one of like your favorite
parts of fried chicken like fried
chicken is what it is because of that
outer crust I mean yeah there's the meat
but you want that crunchiness in man
[Music]
and just the flavors are so later you
know I could taste a little bit of
everything that goes into it no and then
we're talking about the same culprits
here right shallots cilantro ish sauce
and this is a lot of flavors that you'll
see in Asian dishes and if you like
those type of flavors you're definitely
going to love Burmese food but they
somehow do it in a way where I don't
know it's kind of like the flavors are
forward but it's not in your face you
know because when I have like Thai
coconut soup it's just like coconut milk
blasted but whatever it is with the
spices that they put put in this it kind
of balances out that extreme coconut
flavor and you're tasting the fried
quitter you're tasting the chicken and
the broth tasting a little bit of the
spice that's don't and right at the end
when you mix it up to make it red to
make noodles soak up all that
deliciousness
you just become a really happy camper
the cool thing is with this place the
chicken they all used I mean I love
thigh meat when it comes to chicken
because it's never dry has the most
flavor and that's what I'm talking about
I I would normally finish this here but
I'm full as hell
I just ate three dishes and yet Burmese
food a try if you do let me know what
you think about it my god actually I'm
gonna get one more bite I'm [ __ ]
around here I don't know what's wrong
with me come on now David give them give
them that noodle slip that they deserve
oh yeah if you guys want me to try some
other type of food let me know let's get
it on there I'm thinking about having
some East African food on this because I
never had it before but um let me know
in the comments below everybody I'll see
you next time on the best food review
mwah I'm just saying it as if like I got
a plaque for it or something I'm just
I'm really full